hello movie-going fans welcome two
reasons to see my name is ryan right
where i will be providing you with movie
news in three minutes or less for the
last week of May the director of season
one of true detective cary fukunaga has
left the director seat on the remake of
it it is a Stephen King adaptation of a
killer clown who likes to haunt children
I think I should play this clown since I
do everything to disturb children except
for disgusting things like pedophilia
Robert Rodriguez is set to direct the
adaptation of the classic cartoon Jonny
Quest this means that most likely all
the American white characters will be
replaced by Mexican actors it's
announced that the legend of Conan will
be a direct sequel to the original this
time Arnold Schwarzenegger will be
reprising his role but he will be
channeling Conan O'Brien this time
around big news for comic book movies
crisp line may co-star and Wonder Woman
as Steve Trevor Tilda Swinton is in
talks for Doctor Strange to play the
ancient one and Bryan Singer confirms
Caliban will appear in Xmen apocalypse
I'm very excited for this news
regardless of the fact that I have no
[ __ ] clue who any of these characters
are after William Fichtner signs on for
independence day to independence they
too will be directed by roland emmerich
again meaning the great talented actor
william fichtner will appear in another
big-budget shitty movie ex machina 'he's
more machina's if you want to be a true
American actress Alicia vikander isn't
talks to star in the Assassin's Creed
adaptation and the next Bourne movie
this is exciting news because I mean
look at her tell me you don't want to
put your penis in her rub your [ __ ] on
hers the League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen is getting another reboot
since Sean Connery's last film that was
in 2003 if you haven't heard of the 2003
film it's because no one [ __ ] inside
oh it was a box-office flop all right
guys well that's it for the movie news i
found interesting you can go ahead and
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter and you could catch my movie
news and movie reviews on Latino Review
com a website created by that greatest
Mexicans on earth led by robert
rodriguez to call back to that earlier
joke